determina si el sistema no tiene
soluciones o una cantidad infinita de
soluciones y bueno nos dan tres
ecuaciones con tres incógnitas entonces
cómo podemos encontrar la respuesta a
este problema pues lo que voy a hacer es
tomarme la suma y resta habitual de
ecuaciones para ver aquí llegamos así
que algebraica mente voy a trabajar
consume resta y me fijo que esta
ecuación tiene aquí 2x y esta cuestión
tiene 8 x por lo tanto voy a multiplicar
la ecuación de arriba por menos 4 para
que se elimine la equis y que me va a
quedar esto por menos 42 por menos 4 es
menos 8 menos 8 x menos 4 por menos 4 me
da positivo 16 16 y menos 4 por menos 1
me da menos 4 z esto es igual a menos 12
3 x menos 4 es menos 12 y bueno la
agregación número 2 la voy a pasar tal
cual para que se pueda eliminar la equis
y me queda 8 x menos 2 yemas 4 z igual a
7 y entonces vamos a sumar estas
ecuaciones a ver que me dan
el lado izquierdo vamos a ver que
obtengo menos 8 x + 8 x se van de lujo
porque es justo lo que queríamos
después me quedan 16 menos dos en estos
14 james y después me queda menos 4 z4 z
lo cual también se va y aquí empieza un
poco extraño todo este asunto y me queda
que 14 y es igual a menos 12 más 7 lo
cual es menos 5 si te das cuenta aquí
tengo una ecuación que solamente depende
de una variable y esto en un principio
parece ser bastante positivo porque aquí
yo puedo despejar de allí y obtener un
valor para el aiem sin embargo lo
extraño de esto es que me dicen que el
sistema no tiene soluciones o tiene una
infinidad de soluciones pero bueno vamos
a despejar el aire y si divido todo
entre 14 me va a quedar que james es
igual a menos 5 14 a vos hasta aquí
parece estar todo en orden puede ser que
nos pase en alguna ocasión que después
de hacer la eliminación entre dos
ecuaciones obtenga solamente una
ecuación que dependa de una incógnita
sería bastante bueno y aquí ya obtengo
el resultado para ello
vamos a ver qué pasa con las otras dos
ecuaciones fíjate bien aquí tengo dos
ecuaciones de la ecuación número dos y
la ecuación 93 y voy a intentar cancelar
la equis de estas dos a ver si puedo
cancelar la equis y ojos recuerda que
nos dicen que no tiene soluciones o
entre dado caso tiene una infinidad de
soluciones esto quiere decir que los
sistemas no son consistentes pero vamos
a ver qué nos queda así que para esto
voy a multiplicar la segunda ecuación
por dos la segunda ecuación la voy a
dejar tal cual mientras que la tercera
ecuación la voy a multiplicar por dos
para que se canse en la equis y tengo 8
x menos 2 yemas 477 de aquí no he
modificado nada y la tercera ecuación la
voy a multiplicar por 2 y me queda 2 por
menos 4 x es menos 8 x 2
fort y es 2 yemas 202 por 12 está por
menos 2 z es menos 4 z y 2 x menos 14 es
menos 28 y revisarlo aquí va a pasar
algo bastante x
la ecuación número 2 y la ecuación
número 3 y ahora que voy a eliminar las
variables en estas dos ecuaciones
obtengo que 8x menos 8 x es 0 2
20 también 47 menos 4 z es 0 también y
después del otro lado me queda 7 menos
28 de lo cual es menos 21 y esto no
tiene sentido porque cuando 0 es igual a
menos 21 pues esto nunca estas
ecuaciones son inconsistentes no tiene
sentido pensar que a cero se iguala
menos 21 por lo tanto estoy diciendo que
estas dos ecuaciones no tienen solución
y cuando me queda algo de la forma 0
igual a una constante estoy diciendo que
son dos planos que nunca se intersectan
si me quedara cero igual a cero eso
quiere decir que son el mismo plano y
por lo tanto tenemos una infinidad de
soluciones pero aquí como tengo dos
ecuaciones que del lado derecho tienen
distintos números estoy diciendo que son
planos paralelos es decir
imagínate que la gráfica desde el primer
plano es esta de aquí
imagínate que la gráfica de la segunda
ecuación de este segundo
de la ecuación de morada es esta de aquí
es este plano de aquí y estos dos planos
son paralelos y ojo pese a que estas dos
ecuaciones se metían en una respuesta
correcta las últimas dos ecuaciones me
están diciendo que nunca se intersectan
por lo tanto no existe solución